[Music]
Thanks everybody for coming. Um, yeah, I
wanted to talk about some work I've done
recently on trying to figure out uh just
how fast these inference engines are
when you run open models on them.
Uh so the kind of been talking at AI
engineer since it was AI engineer summit
two years ago. Um and the for a long
time it's basically been the like OpenAI
rapper conference, right? It's like
because just because yeah, what am I
going to do? Am I going to run an agent
with BERT? Probably not. Um, and that
was like it was exciting to talk about
all these cool new technologies, see
people building stuff like cursor on top
of them or Devon. Um, but for me as
somebody coming from like having trained
my own models a lot, it was like, oh
man, I want I want to I want to touch
the weights. I want to play with them. I
want to like hack them. And the quality,
but the quality just like wasn't there
yet to do like some of the interesting
stuff. Um, and that's changed. You've
got the Llama series, we've got the Quen
series, we've got Deep Seek, and so now
we're like catching up to like maybe
even literally catching up with the
Frontier Labs, which would be pretty
crazy. Um, but we're at the very least
like at the point where a lot of things
people have been talking about at AI
Engineer for years are possible with
Open Weights models where they weren't
before. Um, and at the same time,
there's also development of the software
stack on top of that. Um, also as
somebody coming from like writing my
writing and running my own pietorch
models, I was like how hard could it be
to run a language model like you just
you torchn.module
wrap a class around it and like yeah I
mean having done stuff with transformers
before it's like oh yeah there's defin
it's a little more complicated with
transformers training looks weird
inference is different um but you know
pretty quickly the state of play has
advanced a lot on how to run a
transformer right KV caching is like you
know just the first thing and then it's
this you know um page detention Now
multi-token prediction, speculative
decoding, all this stuff that's like
pretty hard to write yourself and so you
know you want software to do that for
you probably. Um and so these open
source engines are available now. You
got VLM and SGLang and Tensor TLM. So,
the combination of those two things has
like kind of flipped the uh playing
field around to where there's like you'd
need a really good reason to run your
own models like you're the US government
or something um or you want to run on an
air gap system. Um or you like or you
had to like believe it in your heart,
you know, you had to want open- source
models like the um like new suprime
intellect. You had to be like a
decentralized crypto bro or whatever to
want to run your own open models. Um but
yeah, now the the like uh the situation
has changed. It's really exciting. It
sort of finally makes sense to
self-host.
Um so, uh the just like I wanted to do
this really quickly. I does anybody here
at this AI engineer summit 2023, the
like first one? Anybody? Okay. Did
anybody come to the AI engineering 2011
workshop the day before um uh in the
500t Avenue? Maybe not. I talked to one
or two people who were there. Um so I
gave a talk on on like you know how to
how to do your own AI stuff back then.
Just wanted to pull out like a couple of
slides. Um so like the one of the main
this was like 2023 we're like who's
going to win open models or closed
models? The key statement uh in the talk
was like if capabilities requirements
saturate open models will catch up to
proprietary models and then dominate for
those cases inspired by what you see
with operating systems, databases,
programming languages like as soon as
there's like a a sort of like you know
um capability level that everybody like
that you don't need the absolute best
thing. You just need something that's
good enough. open uh like collaborative
projects tend to catch up and and then
have better properties and that's
happened with open models. So check um
uh yeah so that um that was mostly
around like capabilities um and you know
at the time there was only llama but now
we got a lot um the other one was yeah
talked a little bit about LM inference
libraries at the time and most of them
are gone TGI RIP um uh for example but
VLM was good then it's stuck around now
um yeah so uh I don't know what the
slides in 2027's AI engineering uh
conference are going to look like. But
um the very least like three of my
slides from two years ago were right. Um
so yeah um hopefully it's not those
three slides again in two years. Um
yeah. All right. So what does the LM
engine landscape look like two years
later? Um let's uh take a look. So what
uh what you know we were advising a
bunch of people on how to run like
people were coming to us like I want to
run my own code completion editor in
editors. I want to run like big backfill
jobs to to like um enrich data in
databases with language models. Uh it's
too expensive or uh to run it on OpenAI
or I train my own model so it's too
expensive to run it on a like a provider
like fireworks. They want to run it on
um more generic infrastructure like what
we have at Modal. Um, and so they would
people would come and they'd be like,
"All right, well, how fast can you run
an 8 billion parameter llama model with
SG Lang uh like with 128 tokens in 1,024
tokens out on a Tuesday when Mercury's
in retrograde. Um, and that would like
take at first it took a couple days to
like re you know figure out how to make
sure all the packages are working that
we've got the fastest versions installed
and um like uh that we can give like a,
you know, trustworthy number. got that
down eventually to like you know like an
hour or two um and then built some
benchmarking software so we get it done
in about like 15 20 minutes but then
like you know the people ended up asking
a lot of similar questions so we decided
to just uh you know fifth law of fifth
mantra of performance is uh do it when
they're not looking. Um so like compute
the thing ahead of time and store it. Uh
so we ran a giant benchmark over um like
10 or so different models on VLM suang
and your TLM on about 10 different
context lengths um and put that all up
on the internet. So let's take a look at
that. See I'll drop into this one. So
this is a live version of it. So you can
find this at modal.comlmalmanac.
Um the idea is that this is just one
page in the like you know your almanac
your little book that has the useful
things you need to know to be an LLM
engineer. So to start we've got our
benchmarking results benchmarking
methodology in detail the open source
code for it and a little executive
summary. Um hope to put more stuff up
there as we accumulate the things people
need. Um things about like speculative
decoding and multi-token prediction and
quantization. Um but yeah so to start
off we got this little interface here.
So uh yeah anybody what's a model people
want to see results for
any if uh hopefully that's legible to
people. Anybody got a favorite? H
quen 3
minestral. Okay. Uh excuse me. Uh that
oh man that's that's my boss. I'm not
going to do that one. Um okay we'll do
any engine here. Oh yeah we didn't do uh
so this was fun. SG Lang's Quinn 3
support is a little buggy for the um for
the 8bit quamp that we ran. So I think
we only have results for VLM. We'll
stick with any engine there. Oh yeah, by
the way, if you if you try this thing
out um like you'll see like if there's a
giant tensor of configurations, right?
And we'd love to have that full tensor,
but it doesn't always it's like either
not always possible or um like it's not
clear how to do it. So there's a place
where you can contribute configurations.
So we can build up a nice big database
of like how to run these models. We also
haven't like carefully optimized any of
these things. We started with out of the
box performance for all the engines
because like optimizing 100
configurations is going to take some
time. So we'd love uh like contributions
of optimized implementations especially
tensor TLM which has like a ton of
knobs. Um and they have names like user
buffer like what is that? Um yeah um
okay. Yeah. So, first token under 1
second. Let's say this is this is a
pretty common SLO. Like you want 1
second's nice round number. People feel
like that's like a good amount of time
to wait. I'd say 300 milliseconds is a
tighter one. That's more like
interactive. That's your uh Doerty
threshold. If you're a fan of Holton
Catch Fire um madeup number, but like if
somebody repeats a madeup number enough,
it's a real number. Um so yeah, 300
milliseconds. Okay, so we can get a
throughput of about one request per
second on Quen 3 in the mixture of
experts model on VLM for 128 tokens
in,0284 tokens out. Um, so that's we got
over here we got like a little uh code
snippet here. So it should be the case
that you can UVX modal run this and if
you have a token that should just work
immediately. Uh, and by immediately I
mean after five minutes of loading the
model weights and and spinning up the
model server, but that's as immediate as
it gets. Um, cool. All right, so that's
one result. Uh, who is asking for Quen?
Are you satisfied?
Yeah. Okay, great. Um,
Gemma 327B. All right, on this one,
let's do any engine here. All right,
this was all right. Sorry, we got a
tight filter on this. I'm going to put
the first token filter up. Oh, yeah.
This one we're doing the BF16 quant is
the only one that we could get working
at first. So I think we eventually got
the 8bit quants working. I don't think
that's a hard blocker, but it was the
easiest one to get going was the BF-16.
These are definitely slower. Um, so
you'll see 27 billion parameter models,
so like 10x smaller in uh model weights,
roughly the same number of active
parameters as Quen 3, but we're getting
like about the same um like throughput
requests per second on the same load,
128 in, 1024 out. Um, so yeah, so it's
interesting. you can see sort of which
ones have had more optimization work on
them. I think the Quen 3 models and the
llama model series you see a lot more
optimization. Um this is also one of the
ones where we saw the biggest gap
between um SGI and VLM the Jamo one. So
it looks like the VLM team spent a
little bit more time or Google's
contributed a little bit more to VLM on
getting good results. Oh yeah, let's go.
Oh yeah. So the other thing you'll see
is you generally like so so I just
switched. Sorry, I should say what I'm
doing. So, this is 128 tokens in, 1024
tokens out. Uh, and you can see we're
getting about one request per second on
this guy. U, let's just and the first
token comes back in 400 milliseconds.
Let's flip it to 1024 in and 128 out,
right? So, this is going from like a
reasoning workload to like a rag
workload. big scare quotes on that, but
it's just the difference between whether
you're dominated by decode time, like
more of your tokens are decode or more
of your tokens uh prefill. Uh and what
you'll see very consistently these in
these results is that you get much
higher throughput if you have more like
tokens in the context as opposed to
tokens being generated. very
straightforward if I mean if you know
your transformer architecture it's like
auto reggressive versus parallel like
yeah one of the first things you would
learn if you looked at the you know kind
of the implementation of the
architecture but it's nice to see it
like nice and you know very cleanly more
of an empiricist than a rationalist
myself so I like to see data um and not
like uh chalkboard stuff um so yeah so
uh what I'm getting at here is that the
um the requests per second that we're
seeing here is about four requests per
second for VLM on the same workload but
with like context instead of uh um
generation as what where the majority of
the tokens are. Um so this is u yeah I
gave a talk on GP like GPUs a little bit
earlier today and like one of the big
takeaways there is find things that like
are throughput oriented and involve a
lot of arithmetic and not like moving me
memory around or communication and
that's exactly the difference here. you
have like big matrix matrix
multiplications load the weights one
time use them a bunch um and that's
exactly the difference here and it's a
4x improvement and that's using BF16
which does not have tensor core support
no BF16 has tensor core support but it's
the slow tensor core support compared to
FP8 or FP4 on Hopper and Blackwell and
so you're like you're the real win there
is the shorter like shorter numbers
faster multiplication it's actually
quadratic in the bit width you a big win
as you go down. So this should like if
we were to run some results with FP4 on
Blackwells, you would see an even bigger
gap than just this like 4x improvement.
4x is like barely enough to wake up for,
you know. Um yeah, so that's a little
like not every application can you like
change that. Um like your users might be
bringing queries to you so you don't
have control. Um but the um
uh it can it's more the sort of thing
where you like a product person is like
we should improve the quality. You're
like oh how can I improve the quality
without t like killing our latency.
Don't have it like don't immediately
reach for reasoning. Reach for context
instead because it's going to be cheaper
and you're going to get better perform
like you're you're going to find it
easier to hit your latency SLAs's. I
forgot to point this out, but the
latency is like almost identical in time
in time to first token even though we're
doing 10 times as many tokens. Basically
a free lunch. Um yeah. Okay. So that's
uh that's sort of like how I envision
people using this interface and the
data. Um there is a there's a URL
somewhere where you can just download
the raw data. Um if you're interested in
that, hit me up. The code is also open
source if you want to run some of these
benchmarks yourself. Um I think I have
I'll close there. Lots of other stuff to
talk about like our benchmarking
methodology which is written up here the
uh executive summary which you can share
with your um with your leadership um uh
on like running open models. Um but I'll
take a question or two before we close
out. Yeah.
Yeah.
Yeah. So that so one thing I'll say is
like this is throughput per replica
right so this is one GP is one GPU yeah
one H100 so like what you the way you
solve your like total throughput is by
scaling out rather than scaling up right
um but um so if you want if you want 400
QPS or whatever like eventually you're
just going to have to scale out but to
your question of like yeah how do you
know like you know where like why are we
saying this is the highest throughput
you can get. Yeah. So the answer is like
goes to our benchmarking methodology.
What we do is first we dump like uh you
know a thousand requests and wait for
them all to come back. Calculate the
like thou uh seconds divided uh requests
divided by seconds thousand divided by
how long it took. That's like a maximum
throughput right because we gave it
maximum we exposed the maximum
parallelism to the engine. So presumably
they knew how to they were smart enough
to handle that. Gives you a maximum RPS.
any more than that, you should expect
from queuing theory that the latency
will blow up, right? Then the other side
is um like you send one request at a
time, wait for it to come back, send
another. And that gives us our like
that's the fastest you could possibly
run the server and we sweep between to
get the numbers that are here. Yeah.
Cool. All right. I'll uh got to move on
to the next talk. Uh I'll be outside if
you uh have any questions. Thank you
very much.
[Music]